- I'm so scared.
(rock music)
- We're at Body Electric Tattoo,
and I'm getting my very first tattoo.
- I'm afraid of needles because
last year I got a piercing,
and that piercing got stuck under my skin.
- I know nothing about getting tattoos.
- I'm so scared the blood
is gonna go everywhere,
and it's gonna be like Sweeney Todd.
This is like a Sweeney Todd chair.
Do you notice that?
- Today, I'm getting the pyramids.
Since I'm Egyptian, I
think I need to connect
to that part of me.
And I'm getting "You are full
of wonder," right under it.
- My writing and filmmaking
means a lot to me.
And so I have "When
the world is listening,
"what will you say?"
- I wanna get a really simple
guitar tattoo right over here.
Through my life, and especially
through my childhood,
it was something that
really helped me deal with
a lot of things in my life.
- I hope I don't regret it.
I hope this is a great idea.
- I just don't want
blood to go everywhere.
Is that what's gonna happen?
(rock music)
- I don't know what's happening right now.
Whoa.
(plastic crackling)
Yeah, I have no idea what's going on.
- So you're not just
drilling into my skin?
- Well I am just drilling into your skin.
- It's working.
Oh.
- I'm just going to lie to
my mom as long as I can.
- Oh, oh.
(mechanical buzzing)
(exciting music)
- I feel like the closer to
the boob it gets, it hurts.
- I was just sitting there
and I was just pondering life.
- You know when you have a sharp pencil,
and just someone who's just attacking you?
- It kind of feels like
someone's cutting into my skin.
- Oh, that hurts.
- Are we done?
- I held my breath for 40 minutes.
- [Cameraman] No you didn't.
- I feel relieved that it's done
and there weren't any earthquakes.
- I feel like a new person.
I can't believe I just did this (laughs).
- They look awesome.
I love it.
Look.
I love this.
(rock music)
- I'm really glad I did it,
because the outcome is so beautiful.
- It definitely feels like
someone's ripping off your skin,
but at the end I'm proud
that I had this experience.
- I don't think the fear
of needles will go away.
I think just the way you think of needles.
- A week or so from now I'll
probably forget that it hurt,
and I'll be like, yeah!
Tattoos, needles, great!
Let me go get a flu shot!
- I think I would go get another tattoo.
- Honestly, I feel much stronger.
Seeing it happening made me
feel like oh, I can do anything.
People say look, yeah, once you get one,
you'll get addicted to it.
Nah.
- I hope my mom doesn't kill me.